Lisa's in Ohio hi Lisa welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hi Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up hey so I
learned about you back in February I
have $100,000 student loans so I want to
start my snowball but my really need a
new car so back and sorry when I learned
about you since then I've saved up seven
thousand dollars of cash and my $1,000
emergency funds okay buy a new car the
problem is I just don't know like how to
go about buying a used car my dad is a
mechanic and I've always helped me with
that stuff but he doesn't agree with me
and I know like I'm an adult but I don't
know much about cars you not agree with
you understand um he doesn't think that
I should buy a used car
he thinks I should buy a new car because
he doesn't think that they can be
reliable but there's no way that I can
buy a new car you know what a new car is
after you've owned it a year a used car
yeah and it's reliable it's not amazing
so yeah his famous theory sucks
okay all right
so you have $7,000 what's wrong with the
car you have it's nothing I mean well
it's honest glass one that keeps
breaking down like almost every month
finishes cost you know a lot of money
I've got like almost two hundred and
fifty thousand miles so I've pretty much
run it so it's like it's like $1,000
hoopty right right okay and what do you
make of you right I make between 50 and
60 with overtime okay cool all right and
what do you think it is spending on your
new your next car purchase that's not
new well my goal was $8,000 I don't know
why I picked that but it just sounds
like a good number but I have the 7 and
I keep like hearing people just buy and
like a 2 or $3,000 car and I'm like a
like a pocket the rest of my money or
you know towards my student loans so
yeah I would put I would if I were in
your shoes I would be in the five to six
thousand range okay which is like way
better than what you're driving yeah
it's a whole nother world and if you're
careful when you buy five or six
thousand you buy the right type of car
you can get a lot of reliability and a
lot of life out of a five or six
thousand dollar car okay so okay talk it
through with your dad and say dad you
know I need your help I know your
mechanic give me your advice given that
I'm willing to buy a $5,000 car what
would you do if you're buying a five
thousand well I wouldn't do that so
you're not going to help me at all dad
come on tell me what you would do okay
so I would pick a car that there's a
bunch of them on the road and they have
a good reputation it's a boring car okay
yeah I was thinking I gotta cool though
their exact old Camry and an old Honda
Accord
you know an old you know american-made
is fine too and take it to a mechanic
and tell them you you're willing to
spend $50 with them to go over it for
you if your dad is unwilling to do that
and to tell you what's right and what's
wrong about it
you want something that is ugly with low
miles all we care about is not the sex
appeal of a $5,000 car because there's
no such thing we want reliability this
is the Dave Ramsey chef